our advice to every school district is
to abide by public health guidelines
that the cdc is advising that masks can
delay reduce transmission because of the
dramatic
decline in our coveted numbers effective
monday march 7th the statewide school
mass mandate will be lifted well there
you have it some democrat governors are
now breaking with the white house and
reversing school mask mandates fox
nation host tommy layman joins us on a
tommy tuesday tommy thank you why won't
joe biden acknowledge the decreasing
cases in these blue states
well i think that's really what is
confusing to me you've got a lot of
these democrats a lot of democrat
governors that are doing an about-face
on the mass mandates probably because
they realize it's a political
vulnerability not because they realize
that it really amounts to what is child
abuse but because they see that people
are getting fed up with it some people
are even refusing to comply so they're
understanding and they are reading the
room if you will but the only people
that don't seem to be reading the room
or acknowledging certain science aspects
is the biden administration but i'll
tell you this we're already seeing study
after study coming out the john hopkins
study saying that lockdowns were
ineffective we know that vaccines don't
actually stop the spread they don't stop
transmission what are we going to find
out in the next year or two about what
these mass mandates have done to
children what psychological long-term
effects will these mass have on kids
that's something that the biden
administration though they might have to
answer it during this election cycle
they're certainly going to have to
answer for that in 2024 so it's up to
the governors and it's up to the people
to keep the pressure not only on their
elected leaders locally but also at the
federal level the byte administration
needs to be repeatedly asked why they
want unmask kids yeah and i you know
this is happening today but i wonder
what's happening what's going to happen
in three or four months if there is
another coveted wave
what do you think i mean public
sentiment says that we don't want
lockdowns anymore we want to get back to
normal but there is always that risk
that democrats a lot of cities would
lock up again
well listen i don't think that's going
to be a reality in places where those
democrat or even republican leaders are
politically vulnerable i don't think
that they will ever make that mistake
again but it's up to us the people to
make our leaders understand that they
will be politically vulnerable if they
continue the infringements and the
mandates and the requirements i do
believe the american people on both
sides of the aisle are starting to stand
up to the lunacy realizing what a
ridiculous time this is in american
history and understanding that normalcy
is what we need to return to but it's
not going to change and it will fall
back in places that don't have strong
leadership and don't have people that
are willing to stand up and speak out
because at the end of the day that is
what it will take if you're in a place
that is run by one party like for say
california and your leaders don't feel
that they're politically vulnerable
they're gonna continue this but you make
them a little scared that they're gonna
lose some power and i have a feeling
things will change pretty quickly
meantime tommy most people still haven't
gotten those covid tests that joe biden
promised to send out but now he's going
to spend 30 million bucks to fund
programs that hand out crack pipes to
prevent infection and promote racial
equity why is our tax money going to
this
yeah the shoot-up galleries that of
course former mayor de blasio set up in
new york city that saw overdose death on
the first day now listen the addiction
problem is not one that's easy to solve
but let's go to the actual root cause of
the issue as our vice president kamala
harris likes to discuss often when we
have drugs coming across the border and
we have overdose deaths because of those
drugs coming across the border in the
hundreds of thousands the answer is not
to set up funded shoot-up galleries in
places that people feel comfortable
shooting up their drugs and
not fearing overdose or maybe even still
fearing overdose that's not the solution
and this is only going to add to the
culture of lawlessness now let's keep in
mind in many american cities you can't
go into an indoor restaurant without
being vaccinated but now you can shoot
up illicit drugs the the the wild nature
of this liberalism never ceases to amaze
me yeah also we got to get to this so
we've heard this story before this time
it's house speaker nancy pelosi she
spent half a million dollars on private
jet travel since 2020 despite calling
climate change an existential threat and
she also got religious she said that we
have a religious obligation to fix this
because the planet is god's creation
uh what's your reaction to this uh story
this hypocrisy here
well listen i do believe nancy pelosi
believes that she has a moral obligation
to regulate you and me in our lifestyles
and our fossil fuel use she believes she
has a moral obligation to hamper the
energy sector and those americans that
depend on those fossil fuel jobs but
make no mistake she has no moral
obligation to change her lifestyle in
any way this is the same with her and
other elitists that continue to fly
around on private jets that continue to
use gas guzzling vehicles and it's also
the same as these leaders that are going
mask-less while they tell their
constituents that they must be massed
they believe that they are above the
rules because quite frankly they believe
that they are above you and me again the
solution to all of this is to make them
politically vulnerable and they will pay
the price but that's going to take the
american people standing up and speaking
out and pointing out the hypocrisy and
holding them accountable to make a
change that'll happen the first tuesday
in november will that be a tommy tuesday
you have nine months to find out tommy
larry on tommy tuesday
thank you our good friend tommy i'm
steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm
ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis